schools Across America are ditching
homework and deadlines in favor of
Equitable grading this new approach gets
rid of the 100 point scale and does not
penalize kids for late work or missed
assignments students can even retake
tests or redo assessments we have
limited time Greg we're a Creator not
just for a new generation of losers
we're having a war on measuring things
we don't like to measure things because
we're afraid the people that don't
measure up are going to have hurt
feelings which is actually racist you
you shouldn't worry if a black person
gets a c you know if you don't worry
when a white person gets a c but if you
do you're the racist Katie I'm okay with
no homework
listen I don't really care I really
don't it'll come to fruition rather
they've learned something or they
haven't
I care because in the global competitive
world that we live in American kids are
going to be losing while Asian kids and
every other country is going to be
beating them
did that like lightning okay one more
thing is up next hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else